how's it going rest welcome back to the
correct man like the wet isn't this a
Mother's Goose rhyme why is this here
under the sink
I guess the previous tenant this is so
strange I should sleep or forget about
it of course David you [ __ ] sleep to
everything don't you forget everything
moving for a change of pace huh yes I'm
not working so well I appreciate
polymerase helper this is the creepy
[ __ ] house day 200 oh it's not a kid
died here what kid were living these
beat-up apartments hey maybe they're
lost I should go in shag I don't like
where this is going I do not like where
this is going why did it stop course
there's no kid hair must be getting
tired uh-huh okay where did that come
from my tea no just a broken Cup geez
that's suddenly wait what
who the coffee said a coffee I can't
help you you gotta be this room is
really really strange
this voice isn't TV turning on what is
this I really don't know man but it's
giving me the creeper deepest you really
should clean that up
hi uh Paul it's David hey what's up man
you sound sleepy haha uh yeah I was up
all last night I gotta ask you something
it's now okay hey what Paul I'm Jesse
shot do you know what who used to live
in this room never know you thought the
us landlady I carry is a bad thing well
it seems like he forgot a lot of stuff
and he but I'll have Lana
he sure later [ __ ] the landlady's on
the far end of the first floor I'll go
and see what she knows so that was the
landlady that we interrupted their first
night or whatever the [ __ ] Bros I should
apologize later
oh the first floor my bad my bad my bad
or does it say here oh it's empty
okay well let's just hear them Lannie
hello it's miss David what seemed to be
the batter kadai EMS I just wanted to
ask you something you see about the
remaining can you tell me anything about
it the person who used to live here
there hmm
well you know he's about as old as her
people coming in and going no that's
boy's name I believe he was a man about
your age he suddenly left about a month
ago sad to leave the furniture and use
it however you wouldn't know where he
went and I never heard that no really
just up and left out of blue I just
can't remember the name oh yeah yeah I
could room under the documents to find
penis in it if you like no that's no
need I just sent a little curious thanks
I'll see you around
sounds like alright I was embarrassed
sounds like she really has a fart uh-huh
a man about my age I can only one day I
can oh wow well I'll get back to my room
now
hey pot how are you
that drawer looks like a face I really
drugged-up face alright yeah I plaid
[ __ ] you planned let's go back to sleep
what the [ __ ] what the frog in the dark
no way you can go through that my leg
trip these tracks on the floor what they
lead up to the wall is there something
in his crack I got a brass key what does
that go this Keys pretty fancy I doubt
it's for anything in here so I wonder
where spooky bras this is spooky they're
building up a lot of tension night the
guy's voice
the
kids voices the mirror writing the TV
turning on the coffee ha
it's like poltergeist or something but I
would have thought the landlady would
mention this kind of thing let's go it
on here I mean what the hell is going on
not that I'd care if there were much
goes here
I wouldn't much care if they haunted me
and killed me either what David David
don't have that attitude man but I
wonder about the scrap of paper what was
was what what was the man who lived here
like did this stuff happen when he was
here it was correct man you don't want
to see him not too much he was thinking
about it call it a day and go back to
sleep Oh Shh well I guess not okay now
we're sleeping I don't know why I didn't
do it right away huh
let's add a TV again what what's that
coming from it's it from inside the
house
sounds like a radio it's not the TV what
it's doing that noise Braz what it comes
from here ready yeah
what's uh mices in my closet
not to mention turning on by itself hmm
there's something on the paper here it's
an address I get probably where the key
goes our special place where is that
supposed to be get a paper with an
address all right let's nail a job
I'm waiting for you ah
Wow and what when went out what huh for
David man
oh my poor heart my nipples against Iron
Man you know so you slept well last
night sorry you had to sleep on my couch
nah I should be sorry for coming over so
late okay wasn't expecting it bad if you
want my sweet eyes you can do this call
me I mean but don't sweat it but hey did
something happen you don't look too high
yeah oh there says that I had no reason
or maybe I felt like intruding into the
newlyweds love nest hey why you ha ha
just kidding seriously though you can
tell me today anything happens okay I'll
do whatever I can for you alright I'm
glad you have a buddy who look out for
his friends hey you might follow me now
Paul you are so cool oh yeah I heard
about that Aryan sorry about Shirley
thing I told her off for that don't
worry about it
it's not- fault well it's not about
whose fault it and it's not happy about
don't let it get it done alright I know
you got your mother like after but I
think I'm a volatile new people as if a
guy like me could find a date what
you're gorgeous David don't be like that
I'm just some clerk with our mom in the
hospital and the girl I wanted to marry
ran from me man don't be so just say see
you keep up with that moping and now
you'll have your personnel raincloud
yeah well I'll be careful
oh so I'm going to go on a little trip
don't want to waste my vacation you know
oh great
oh sorry oh great idea where you going
just some way I been wandering about
I'll call you when I get there
sweet send me a postcard
do people still do that breakfast ready
Paul dammit we're eating - yeah I'm not
hungry I'll be going ah that's too bad
come by any time you like Thank You
Marian so who's Shirley is ex-girlfriend
or whatever I guess so I guess so
there looks like this address is in the
mountain about five hour drive did the
former tenant go here I just want to ask
him about this room maybe he'll know
something so we're going to that address
even though the thing happened he'll go
right now
stand place anyway I can't stand this
place anyway okay I don't know about
this David I don't know about this
prologue David's room and and we do a
save there
jeez it's gotten dark but this is the
place no Daft huge place looks like a
hotel wouldn't he be here I guess I lied
a check huh I don't like this bras I
really don't like this this is I got old
charger something a faded board giving
you a Serene's okay it is a hotel a
hotel register oh I do not know me piace
akela is painted over it won't open
it's locked okay okay what the [ __ ]
last one [ __ ] ah
no luck bro ChaCha don't ever worry
about it's gonna be fun hey are you
scared it's just an Hotel Justin oh no
Oh which number did the key thing let's
see her it doesn't say oh well what do
you do so I guess I gotta use the key on
the right door oh yeah I love ya grand
piano
oh this is pretty cozy I got flowers and
everything I can walk over the couch
with no problem
I flowers how you doing well I mounted
ear
Oh fancy fancy fancy fancy all right
I don't really know what I'm doing but I
just but that's okay well it's a bar
it reminds me of the shiny you know with
empty hotel in Oh what's it say here
oh we can't go to the bar I don't really
know why are we going brother hell of a
cupboard I know nobody no one a shotgun
does supply whichever way the wind is
blowing whoa creepy as [ __ ] man nothing
in the desk drawer Oh jab bloody Fonz
carpet sandwich
okay I was only a crack in the woods as
a note but it was a special place
she loved the pretty room with this big
mirror she would wonder what to wear for
dinner but now it's just me I thought it
might help to come here but it didn't
there's only emptiness that's creepy man
the rule on this page it matches the one
from my room so the former tenant did
come here I wonder if he's still here so
he got dumped huh the note at home did
mention that and our special place he
came here with her well why could it be
then I don't wanna know I don't know too
bad huh guess he didn't get laid ha ha
but a new sorry sorry about that
well I guess I'll just be go and then
there's a note there on the thing
due to employee income competence and
lost Keith the library is temporary
fellas we apologize for the wait if the
key is missing
shouldn't I have no
I don't know what I'm the one I really
don't I really don't but that's okay
well I guess we're done here I should
look around a little more huh I don't
really want to look around a lot more I
wish I knew which room like I can go to
or whatever I think I should everything
doesn't worry
what is this did we go here staff only
asked oh I don't have that oh we haven't
been in here this looked like the
bathroom
I says treasure hunt me dear mom dad
this is a clue one two three oh it's one
of the tables I think I guess some kids
staying here drew this ha ha she'll look
for your treasure why don't we have
better things to do okay so it kind of
look like the the dining room bridge
shadows but I'm not sure honestly uh
yeah it is okay so it was this table I
think
ah something's under the table gold key
there's a paper beside it you found the
treasure Congrats huh well oh I'll say
there okay maybe it's here due to it
okay
I know this I use the gold key cool oh
there's another key okay okay and we
know where to go next
I don't want to go there next that's
sound is there just okay maybe I'll use
these later do you consider yourself
kind you don't get to decide it's
decided in the unconscious even if you
believe you are cold-hearted you may be
warm and emotional inside and they will
sniff it out they will be lured by your
kindness and they will drag you away Oh
some kind of a cult book
I bet Paul would love this he's way too
into that stuff for this age Paul that
crazy son of a [ __ ] huh okay I think
what the [ __ ] is bad
someone there Mose beside you you look
more like a seal actually a really happy
seal this smiling more than before okay
it should be over here yeah
okay so zero it should be here yes
there's something shimmering up hey hey
push this
there we go now can guess what's under
dresses yeah
wire cutters I know exactly where we can
you say
ah knock - I think it is burned
must I immerse you look it looks so
lovely tonight I think I think I'm in
love
shut up rose die